mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur das
restlos wünschte ihnen viel vergnügen
die bühne des kkl in luzern ein großer
auftritt ist hier programm
das braucht mut und um den geht heute
bei kulturplatz
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen auf dem kulturplatz
john wayne sagte es einst zu mut ist
wenn man todesangst hat und sich
trotzdem in den sattel schwingt aber
hier gibt sich heute niemand mit einem
pferderücken zufrieden nein hier will
man sich viel höher hinauf schwingen
nämlich auf die große bühne des
renommierten musikfestivals 132
jugendliche aus aller welt kapern das
kkl
sie sind teil eines internationalen
projekts das jeden kindern den zugang
zur musik vermittelt die in sonst nicht
hätten wir begleiten die vorbereitungen
zum großen konzert und zeigen ihnen
weitere eindrückliche beispiele dafür
wie kindern und jugendlichen der zugang
zur kultur geebnet wird und überall
heißt das zauberwort mut
wie gehts wie geht's dir gut und du bist
du bereit fürs konzert ja nein das ist
ein profi nein kann profi aber ich mache
das ja nicht zum ersten mal
wir sehen uns nachher das ist miguel
almeida erst zwölf jahre alt und spielt
die viola ein wunder kinder aber ist er
nicht wie auch die anderen kinder hier
keine wunderkinder sind trotzdem spielen
sie heute ein hochstehendes klassisches
konzert mit werken von brahms mozart und
schostakowitsch die organisation die das
ermöglicht heißt super spanisch für
überwindung dazu wird mir mehr erfahren
und haben miguel die letzten monate
begleitet etwa bei seinen proben im
orchester von super in lugano ein
schulfreien mittwochnachmittag in lugano
miguel almeida geht nicht spielen oder
in die badi sondern zur probe des
jugendorchesters von super rossis
[Musik]
der 12 jährige ist seit über zwei jahren
dabei er übt acht stunden jede woche
immer in der freizeit
das verlangt hingabe konzentration und
durchhaltewillen
gemeinsam geht das leichter deshalb gibt
es bei super von anfang an gruppen
proben keinen einzelunterricht
[Musik]
das system der gruppen dient sowohl der
gegenseitigen hilfe wie auch dem
vergleich und im wettbewerb
alle helfen und stimulieren sich
gegenseitig das stärkt das gruppengefühl
wie in einem fußballteam wir musizieren
ja hier nicht nur gemeinsam sondern
lernen die grundsätze der zusammenarbeit
[Musik]
eines unserer vielen ziele ist die
charakterbildung die musik dient auch
dazu dass opera orchester übt
zielstrebig auf konzertauftritt dahin
das schafft erfolgserlebnisse die diesen
kindern besonders gut tun
[Musik]
unsere auswahl zwei familien die
unterstützung brauchen die es schwierig
haben die ihren kindern eine
musikerziehung bezahlen könnten
dann gab es unterricht und gratis
instrumenten erreichen wir diese
gesellschaftsschicht und finden dort
auch spezielle talente die finden sich
bei allen kindern
es geht nicht um perfektion sondern um
selbstvertrauen und gemeinsinn für
beides scheint sich orchestermusik
bestens zu eignen
ja die aufregung steigt und diese
letzten momente des wartens sind für
viele die größere herausforderung als
der eigentliche auftritt
währenddessen machen wir uns noch einige
gedanken die kulturförderung sonst noch
funktionieren kann für jugendliche jetzt
zum beispiel literatur und tonners
das große ziel ein tanz auftritt im
opernhaus zürich
[Musik]
am anfang sind die jugendlichen kaum zu
motivieren
erschöpfte forstprojekte reicher dass
sich alle bewegen und vergessen bin ich
gut bin ich schlecht sieht das schöne
ist dass wir stets etwas peinlich ist
das lässt so richtig lässt findet man es
an der sekundarschule in wien noch nicht
dieses angeordnete projekt das aus
goethes faust eine tanzperformance
machen soll
die blauelinie blanke häufig sehr
konkret wir fühlen mit mit schritt und
ich auch noch nicht auf hunde haben das
heißt er ist nicht zu beneiden
der choreograf philipp engel nur fünf
nachmittage und eine trainingswoche lang
hat der zeit diese 17 teenies in opern
stars zu verwandeln
warum wir uns halten die konzentrierte
drauf und auch so genau
[Musik]
die schulbank
es gibt ja der anfang im faust oder der
faust selber wo eigentlich möchte aus
dem wissens alltagssprache und da
einfach so die tische sind für mich sehr
wichtig
[Musik]
erst ein paar einzelne bewegungsabläufe
sind definiert
dafür ist schon klar dass es nur eine
feste rolle geben wird den mephisto
robin soll es richten
habe kann das nicht nein
[Musik]
null bock auf ost und schon nächste
woche verlagern sich die proben ins
opernhaus ob das den krieg bringt für
die motivation
während dieser jugendliche noch mit
ihren hemmungen kämpfen sind diese
lehrlinge schon mittendrin in ihrem
herausfordernden projekt in ihrem ersten
lehrjahr als mode gestaltende sollen sie
sich als literaten bewähren
[Musik]
vom tuch zum buch eine mutprobe die sie
ins junge literatur labor yunnan der
bärengasse in zürich fühlt das ist ein
ort zum experimentieren mit sprache ein
schreib labor wohl auch für jugendliche
die wenig bis gar nichts mit literatur
anfangen können statt allgemeinbildenden
unterricht zu geben fädelte lehrer lukas
tobler für seine schüler neuen schreibt
treffen beim literatur profi andre blatt
die mehrheits 1
das ziel ist ambitioniert ein buch über
seide soll es werden
nun gibt es eben bücher und bücher und
wir machen eben unseres und unseres ist
eine momentaufnahme in der ihre stimmen
zur seite zur sprache kommen
mit seide arbeiten die lehrlinge täglich
jetzt versuchen sie sich literarisch an
diesem stoff sie sammeln informationen
um daraus texte zu geben
viele sind noch verunsichert weil gottes
geht dieser währung gesteuertes thema
ist das mit was ist material was ich
sehe wie fühlt sich das an
und wir sind ja nicht da um die
geschichte neu zu schreiben sondern wir
schreiben etwas was uns betrifft aber
diesen schritt so kritisiertes zufolge
steht dann das live plattform ihr ist
das schwierig obwohl mir und jetzt lernt
dass ein reines tv vom lehrer blog
darüber wenn ich sage sicher bist mache
natürlich sind sechs machten die bevor
ich darf sie unter stress das was sie
sie müssen vielen ansprüchen gerecht
werden sich selbst dem schreibcoach und
der späteren leserschaft dann gibt es
genau das was in einem buch passieren
muss die spannung
eine woche später in der motto der
schweizerischen fachschule für mode und
gestaltung
das freie projekt treibt die lehrlinge
auch bei ihrer arbeit im atelier um
fügt man sich sicher ich bin neu
ausgeschrieben
ja ich bin schwul bin schrieb ist man
einfach wirklich und nicht so wirken
weiß nicht was wir machen deshalb sei
die zeichnung mit schnittmustern
einmaleffekt sind auch richtig und das
feature gewisse sicherheit und im
schreiben sind zu haben
für mich sei weil es schon ganz andere
prozesse und ich fiel mehrfach mussten
im corpus was drin umschwirrt und
durchsatz vielmehr nach arbeitsablauf im
schreibkurs am gleichen tag in der mode
geht es ums gegenlesen es muss passen
wie bei einer fassen heißt man muss sich
das genau vorstellen können was sie
erzählt
je persönlicher und sinnlicher die
schilderung desto besser passte der duft
von frisch gebackenen gibt philips den
kaffee in meinen augen
man fängt an zu wippen da muss ganz
locker sie war so happy es wird super
zwei fliegen auf einen schlag der anfang
noch kein auftrag das vortragen heißt
sich überwinden
da braucht es noch viel übung bis zur
lesung in zwei monaten
bist du bereit ja ich bin bereit 20
minuten beginnt das konzert
ich kann es kaum abwarten also ich hab
mir erzählt
die
vorangebracht hat auf allen ebenen mit
musik geht alles leichter
auch der wöchentliche putzdienst doch
für miguel bedeutet musik mittlerweile
mehr aus nur vergnügen
sie bietet ihm eine lebenserfahrung an
der erwachsen kann
wie hat sich ihr sohn entwickelt seit
der im orchester mit macht
miguel ist sehr glücklich
er liebt diese musikproben aber er hat
sich auch in der schule weiter
entwickelt opera tut ihm gut
persönlich wie schulisch seit er ein
instrument spielt ist er viel
konzentrierter auch in der schule
er bekommt jetzt auch viel bessere noten
er muss nicht mal mehr hausaufgaben
machen weil er sich im unterricht so gut
konzentriert das hat er alles mit der
musik gelernt
seit er bei super da mitmacht
ich hätte ja nie gedacht dass miguel
jemals ein klassisches instrument
spielen für die musiker klassiker
[Musik]
das ist die walser passage die mir am
besten gefällt
sehr schön warum hast du ausgerechnet
die bratsche gewählt - ein interessantes
instrument von dem hatte ich noch nie
gehört
ich kannte nur geige cello und
kontrabass also entschied ich mich für
die branche er wollte schon als
zweijähriger knirps auf jedem instrument
spielen
auch hier in den ferien an einem
tanzfest da wollte er auch der spieler
aber er wusste natürlich nicht wie oder
hier
da wollte er unbedingt gitarre spielen
musik machen und die leute zu
unterhalten
ein musiker vielleicht ja aber ich hätte
nie gedacht dass er einmal bratsche
spielen würde
private musikstunden für ihren sohn
bezahlen nein niemals
wir haben das einmal abgeklärt für
gitarre stunden aber die kosten sind
torrent der zwölfjährige ist kein
musikalisches wunderkind das zuhause
stunden lang übt im gegenteil nur hat er
weniger zeit für fußballer seine freunde
weil er sich fürs mitmachen im
jugendorchester entschieden habt wärst
du ohne super je auf die idee gekommen
in einem orchester zu spielen
niemals konkurrenzdruck nein da gibt es
keine konkurrenz
[Musik]
wir sind wie eine familie
wir lieben uns schon als ich anfing bei
super erlebte ich diese inspiration
sobald die spiele befreie ich mich von
allem und habe einfach freude
julis ist ascanio ließ askania sie
dirigieren dieses internationale
jugendorchester was ist der hauptzweck
der musikalischen erziehung die
musikalische erziehung wie wir sie in
diesem system begreifen ist eine
umfassende bildung für kinder und
jugendliche durch musik in dieser
disziplin vereinen sich mathematik und
gefühle einfach alles das spiel im
orchester scheint ein guter weg zu sein
um soziale kompetenzen zu schulen
was ist das geheimnis da gibt es keine
geheimnisse
diese methode wurde in venezuela
entwickelt und hat sich seit 43 jahren
bewährt sie lehrt die kinder auf
großartige weise disziplin und weckt
ihnen gleichzeitig die leidenschaft das
sind die beiden eben die objektive und
subjektive ein orchester ist wie ein
land oder eine kleine gesellschaft wo
jeder seine rechte hat aber auch die
anderen respektieren muss
du kannst dich maximal entwickeln ohne
den anderen etwas wegzunehmen
es ist großenteils technische arbeit
aber zuerst muss man im kind die
leidenschaft legen damit es sich in sein
instrument verliebt und dieses studium
vertiefen also glauben sie nicht an
wunder sondern harte arbeit
ich glaube an wunder wenn man ganz
fester verarbeitet das ist das einzige
weg um wunder zu bewirken
ich kann nicht sagen ob heute ein wunder
geschehen wird aber das konzert bestimmt
sehr schön der esprit ist da und der ist
ja teil des bundes bei wir haben auch
die ganze woche sehr hart dafür
gearbeitet und viel gefordert sieben
stunden pro tag vor über 40 jahren als
teenager waren sie selber ein
musikstudent was geschah damals
vor 43 jahren gab es in caracas kein
orchester keine hoffnung keine
musikalische zukunft besonders aber der
meistro rosen tonio april wollte uns den
musikstudenten von damals eine chance
bieten
er hat sein leben dafür gegeben sich mit
leib und seele eingesetzt um diese
visionäre bewegung ins leben zu rufen
die heute noch inspiration bietet auf
der ganzen welt
das lampenfieber steigt hier im
backstage-bereich des kkl und wir werfen
nochmals einen blick zu unseren jungen
literaten und tänzerin denn sie wollen
und sollen ja auch eines tages vor
publikum treten mittagspause für die
sekundarklasse aus dem zürcher oberland
der tapetenwechsel weg aus der turnhalle
in den probesaal des opernhauses zürich
motiviert
[Musik]
rubin macht dachte schnitzler ist luft
wird also in dem jugend schon passiert
dass jetzt innerhalb von kassier theater
und langsam auf stockers für mich viel
passiert glaubt dass man schweißt sagt
verlust von mehreren alter bis zu machen
immer geklappt
[Musik]
er sollte nervös ich denke wenn es
anfängt ist also geister sind plötzlich
war die jungs wahnsinnig nervös sogar
fünf minuten vor den rückseiten muss
jetzt gebracht sobald die türen könnt
jetzt nur noch faust toi toi toi
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das gefühl auf des treffens
so wie sie jetzt da drauf sind und
reviere gespürt doch was das heißt
dressel theater und das durchgestanden
und erlöst sie macht doch mehr mit
eingestellt jubel stolz und
erleichterung hier vor freudige
anspannung da heute ist tag der
öffentlichen lesung verwandte freunde
bekannte
alle sind sie ins literatur labor
gekommen alle wollen sie sehen und hören
was die angehenden modemacher
literarisch geschaffen haben denn es ist
vollbracht
ihr buch seitensprünge ist erschienen
pfiffigen geschichten persönliche
erlebnisse anekdoten über seide das
resultat überzeugt
so sehr dass künstler aus den texten
videoinstallationen für das literatur
labor gemacht haben
[Musik]
opel oder dunkel schwarz oder weiß hat
ihren preis und kann sie tragen wie man
will morgen auf eine starke person wohl
einiges noch fest annehmen würde
und noch einer sehr schwachen person
fast lose von kleidungsstück hängen
würde
sechs monate kreativer schreibkurs was
hat er den lehrlingen gebracht das
glaube ich nicht dass ich einfach mal
drauflos schreiber ohne große
erwartungen und dann okay man weiß oder
wenn es nicht weiß dass man merke ja ich
hatte eigentlich gedacht sie geeignet
ist was in eigenen stil als trainer im
schrieb aroma und ich denke dass dein
alltag
ich setze auch coach und regla die
mehrheits ist stolz meine aufgabe war es
nur 23 blitzgescheite motivierte junge
menschen dazu zu bringen dass sie sich
überlegen mit welcher stimme sie
schreiben war haye
bühne frei für die jungautoren wir
versuchen zeige in worte zu kleiden
seide ein thema über das wir stundenlang
reden und schreiben können
seide seite um seite werden wir beim
schreiben eine blockade haben können
lassen wir beim nennen gelangt freien
lauf und habt ihr gehört dass es für
ihre arbeit heiniger frank nicht nur vor
euch hin seite gesicht in die augen vom
blatt zum text zum buch vom stoff zum
ganzen kleid nähen und schreiben der
zusammenhang verzaubert und die
seitensprünge sind vollendet literatur
selbst gemacht ein wahrer aufsteller
jetzt freuen wir uns hier auf das große
konzert zuerst noch zwei hinweise in
eigener sache nächste woche machen wir
station im kinderspital zürich wo kunst
neuerdings trost verspricht
und gleich nach herford dog und erklärt
wie das funktioniert mit der liebe auf
den ersten klick wir von kulturplatz
wünschen eine gute woche und denken sie
dran mut heißt das zauberwort tschüss
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos